Let's go next to Ivan from Phenix, Arizona.
Ivan, you're on the air.
Hi, David.
How are you?
Good.
So I'm currently a senior in high school,
and recently I've been paying attention to
the local elections over here.
And I'm actually in Goa, but like also the
politicians here.
And I've realized that, like a lot of them
are extremely slimy people.
I'm just curious how I can get more involved
to make sure that these types of people aren't
elected anymore, especially as Arizona is
becoming more left leaning.
Yeah, I mean, you know, pay attention to whether
there is a candidate that you find to be not
slimy that runs at the city council level,
mayoral level, whatever, and work for their
campaign.
I mean, there's no all of these upstart campaigns
want volunteers.
And if you don't see anybody who you want
to put your efforts behind, consider maybe
running yourself at some point.
But that's this is exactly the right question.
You don't like the people that are representing
you.
And so you have you can have a voice in that.
And that means not only can you will you be
able to vote, I don't know if you're already
old enough to vote.
Not only will you be able to vote, but you
can run.
You can support other candidates.
You can draft other candidates and say to
someone, you should really run against this
person.
So, yeah, the local level is where you can
actually have the biggest and fastest impact
in many ways.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking last year.
I had the opportunity to go to the Capitol
for like an environmental day and speak with
the my my representative.
And he just started questioning like this.
Sources are biology books came from.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It was like an absolute mess.
So I just want to make sure, like, these types
of people aren't able to have any power.
You know, I just recently was reading that
the the most dangerous state to be in from
the standpoint of the pandemic is Arizona.
Have you.
Does that resonate with you in terms of what
you've seen?
Oh, yeah.
It's a complete mess here.
People don't wear masks in stores like I work
at a Wal-Mart.
And probably one third of the people aren't
wearing masks when they're inside schools.
Nobody wears masks.
It's it's just really bad here.
And how about as far as vaccines?
Are you hearing a lot of anti vaccine talk?
I'm actually I haven't heard too much anti
vax talk, just more so people still believing
that the virus is just a Democratic hoax.
Well, the weird thing about that is you'd
think that it would have ended when Joe Biden
was sworn in.
Yeah, I mean, I my my uncle kept saying that
come November 3rd, the coronavirus is going
to be over.
Right.
Look, here we are.
Have you talked to him and asked what happened?
I haven't actually.
We don't have the strongest relation.
OK, yeah, I can guess why.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, listen, Ivan, you're asking all the
right questions.
You're doing all the right things.
It's great that you're involved.
Well, thank you very much, David.
All right, Ivan from Phenix.
Fantastic, fantastic to have young folks involved.
Very, very important.